I'm Liam Zaloga, Medeo
at Arkansas State
University, my
specialty pathology, and
my contact information
is on this slide.
This is a talk
about neurological
birth defects,
so we'll start
off with the
embryogenesis.
That'll just be reviewed.
review so we can use it
to discuss congenital
neurological defects.
See here in the
objectives I didn't
highlight anything there,
but it's
important to know
these things
for this topic.
The most common
neural tube defects
will go through
like spina bifida,
most common
forebrain posterior
fossa lesions, I
list a couple here,
well the most
common anomalies,
cervical myelia
and hydrocephalus
are related and
brain injuries
around the time of birth.
These are all the
topics we're going to
talk about today and
the different categories
therein for the
different disorders.
And here's the
neuroembryo review.
So this is going to
be development of
the gastrula about
day 17 of gestation
from an epiblast and
hypoblast bilaminar
disc into a trilaminar
disc, where those
later develop into
ectoderm, mesoderm,
and endoderm,
and those cells
there will develop
into the fetus.
All the different
organs and tissues
of the body are
going to be produced.
Notogenesis is an
important part of that,
and there's something
called the notochord
here that develops
between the ectoderm and
the endoderm, and it
comes from the epiglass
cells, and that's going
to help the nervous
system develop and
become part of it too.
It degenerates
afterwards, and
its remnants are
nucleus propulsors
in the
intervertebral discs.
There's a couple
of images or so of
the bilaminar,
trilaminar, and
organogenesis, how
that process occurs.
But we're going to
talk about that too.
So the notochord
induces cells
around it, the
ectoderm specifically,
to begin thickening
and become
what's called
the neural plate
in the process
of neuralation.
So, this neural
plate is going
to narrow and
elongate and be kind
of like a burrito
or a canole.
These are the
neural pores at the
end. They're
going to fuse too.
Neural plate's edges,
seen here,
are going to
form folds and
at the tips
of these folds
are going to be
neural crest cells.
And those neural
crest cells are going
to migrate through
the body and form
other cells and
tissues of the body.
What the neural
plate is going
to do is fold
up on itself.
And where the
neural crest cells
are, it's going to join
together and form
the neural tube.
At this time,
somites, which are
blocks of mesoderm,
are going to form
alongside the neural
tube, laterally, on
each side. That'll be
about the third week
of embryogenesis.
A little later on,
the different parts
of this fused neural
tube are going to
form segments that
are going to form
different parts of the
nervous system, and
you can see a bunch
of them labeled here.
This will be brain
and brain stem
structures, and
this part will be
spinal cord, as
it's labeled here.
So in about nine weeks,
this is a diagram
that shows the neural
tube has all these
primitive structures
growing around it there's
some of them listed
here the tube itself
it will become the
inside of the nervous
system it'll become
the ventricular system
and the spinal
appendical canal which is
shown here in a diagram
with its choroid
plexus locations
indicated on on the right.
In about four to six
weeks this is what the
different segments are
going to be producing
at this stage of
development, what's
labeled here, in the
process of segmentation.
Okay, so you can see
here this is a nine
month old central
nervous system, you
know, well brainstem
and brain, and the
diagram that you can
see that it's at four
months, it's not
fully developed, it's
got a smooth structure,
not many grooves,
not many sulci, not
many gyri but they you
know maybe can develop
as the brain develops
all the proper sulci
and gyri and the way
that happens is that
glial cells need to
extend processes from
their cell bodies from
the inner surface all
the way to the outer
surface of that structure
along the neural
tube and then the cells
are going to migrate
in the cerebral cortex
it's going to be
six layers that they're
going to make and
that's going to be
pre-programmed they're
going to know where
they're supposed to go and
the cerebellum is
going to have three and
then the brain is
going to take a shape
as this migration
proceeds and these neurons
migrate wherever they
need to go in the
different layers of
the cortex cerebellum
and other parts of
the nervous system.
There's a book
called First Aid
and it discusses
a little bit more
so I thought I'd
include that.
I already told you
about the nucleus
pulpsis and it
induces the acroderm
to make neural
acroderm which is going
to make those
neural crest cells.
Those neural crest
cells, they're
going to migrate you
know with maturation
and form the
peripheral nervous
system, neurons, but
also glial cells.
The neural tube,
which came from the
neural plate, has
neuroepithelia in
it and that's going
to form CNS neurons
and glial cells.
So this is where the
neural crest cells
are going to be
located and they're
going to migrate
from here and then go
out to the peripheral
nervous system.
Now we're going to talk
about the
different defects.
This is just something
general about
all these different
neural tube defects.
So failure of that
tube or the pores to
close around four weeks
leaves a persistent
connection from the
amniotic cavity to the
spinal canal. So
there's going to be some
changes. So mom's serum
and amniotic fluid
might have increased
levels of alpha
-fetoprotein except in
the MTD called spina
bifida occulta, and
you'll have normal AMP.
If you want to confirm
possible neural
tube defect at
about this stage,
amniotic senacolinesterase
could be sampled
and see if that's
elevated as a confirmatory
test. I list many
different risk factors,
and you can see
there's many different
drugs that can cause
these types of defects,
but there's also certain
conditions of the
mother, too, like
malnutrition, alcoholism,
low folate,
obesity, diabetes.
There are some
genetic determinants.
For example,
some people can
have genes that mutate
folate-responsive
receptors or
enzyme pathways.
The folate
insufficiency is
associated with
neural tube defects.
So it's currently
recommended if
the females
thinking of becoming
pregnant, they
should consume at
least 0.4 mg per
day of folic acid.
Also, maternal
diabetes has
a significant
risk of NTDs.
So down to the bottom,
here's the different
conditions we'll be
going over for neural
tube defects and here's
a neural tube partly
all folded up. The
neural pores are still
open.
These are going
to close. This is
the caudal end.
This is the rospiral
end. So this is
the rospiral neural
pore and there's
the caudal neural
pore. Kind of looks
like a cannoli
that's shown
over here on the
right which is an
Italian dessert.
Spina bifida occulta.
okay so in this
diagram you can see
there's a defect in this
bony vertebra and
it's along this arch
so that's the defect
of spina bifida occulta
it's in the bony
vertebra but this is
a closed neural tube
defect because there's
a layer of skin over
the nervous system
elements you know
the spinal cord and
leptomeninges so they
are in their proper
location in the spinal
canal and that area
is covered by a layer
of skin and soft tissues
so they're usually
asymptomatic and
there's no protrusion
of meninges or anything
else through that
defect there might be
something on the skin
which is kind of a signpost
that this could be
spina bifida occulta
but this one here
hypertrichosis you know
hair growth in that
lower back midline area
being the most common
okay but There can
also be lipomas and
residual tail, capillary
malformations,
neumangiomas might be in
that location and make
you think that there
might be some sort of
neural tube defect.
Okay.
Here's the next
one, meningocel. So
as you can imagine,
it's going to involve
the meninges. And
you can see in
the diagram, the
meninges are dilated
and extending through
a bony defect.
Because this is
protruding through,
there's going to be skin
barrier. It's going
to be defective.
It's going to be thin.
So sometimes it's
there and sometimes
it's not. Sometimes
it's just these
leptomeninges that
are seen. Here's a
photograph showing a
large meninzocele
in the lumbosacral
region midline, and
this looks like it's
the meninges that
have herniated through
the vertebral arch
of the lower back.
The spinal cord
is usually normal,
and it's in its
correct location
in the canal. It's
just meninges.
most are covered
with skin and pose
no threat but if
there's any leakage
or if it's really
thin and translucent
then it might need
surgery to prevent
infections in the
nervous system
an exam for
neurogenic bladder
should be performed
to make sure none of
the nervous system has
been damaged in this
region because in the
lumbosacral region and
these needs check for
it because 90% of
children with spina bifida
like meningocele are
incontinent of urine
something damaged
along the way
somewhere. Okay,
meningomyelocele
and myloschisis.
This or schisis.
These are open
neural tube defects
because as you can
see in the diagram of
myelomeningocele the
skin is either thin or
absent. So more often
than not it's not going
to be there. So you're
going to see the layers
of the leptomeninges
and there's going to
be failure of the
neural tube to close up.
So in this image,
the central
canal is seen
going through
horizontally on
the neural placode.
And I wrote here
what the placode was.
It's going to be the
flat plate that's
not folded up. That's
called the placode.
And it's a
myelomeningocele. So the
myelomeningocele,
which is the spine,
and the meninges,
are going to be
herniating through
the bony defect.
And as I already
talked about the skin,
these are almost
always associated
with what's
called a Chiari II
malformation, which
we'll go over later.
They involve a different
part of the CNS.
And next, we're going
to go on to myloscesis,
which is focused
on the spinal cord.
There's also something
called rachyschisis,
which is a spinal
column focus.
So, this is most
severe, and what you're
going to see is exposed
and unfused neural
tissue without skin.
So, schisis, there's
a lack of fusion of
these structures.
So, it's going
to be without
skin or meningeal
covering.
These terms rachyschisis
and myloschisis
are often used
interchangeably
because this
rachyschisis has to
exist or the myloschisis
to exist too.
So that's why they use
them interchangeably.
Okay,
moving on,
encephalocele and
cranial meningocele,
so it's just not just,
it's not just the
lower back, it can
be anywhere along
the neural tube where
there's a defect.
Okay,
so encephalocele is
going to protrude
through a midline
cranial defect,
another name is
cranium bifidum,
cranium bifidum is
encephalocele and
the skull doesn't
close in one location
completely during
development.
So, there's going
to be a CSF-filled
meningeal *** when it
comes to meningocele.
When it's an
embolocele, it contains
the *** plus some
cerebral cortex, or
cerebellum, or parts
of the brain stem.
okay it's associated
with other cns
developmental
abnormalities like that I
list here there's a
Chiari malformation
again just like the
one we just talked
about and one called
the Dandy Walker
anomaly we'll talk
about that one too
because there's like
for example stenosis
so that's part of the
ventricular system,
the aqueduct, there's
going to be increased
risk for developing
hydrocephalus, okay,
which might need to
be treated because it
can have morbidity
and mortality effects.
This is a severe
form of neural
tube defect called
anencephaly.
So as you can imagine,
A means without
and encephaly is
referring to CNS
structures. So, this
is going to be an
open neural tube
defect because there's
going to be a failure
of the rospiral
neural core to
close by week four.
Okay, so there's
going to be no
cephalad neural
tube closure.
So, there's going
to be connection
from the amnion to
the spinal canal.
It's going to be
there persistently.
There's going to be
no forebrain. There's
going to be an
open calvarium too.
The cranial vault is
going to be absent.
The skin is going
to be continuous
with the nervous tissue.
The cerebral hemispheres
and cerebellum
are usually
absent. And really
the only thing
that's left is a
residual of the brain
stem structures.
And because I mentioned
that the amnion and
spinal canal were
connected, there's going
to be alpha fetoprotein
that's going to be
detectable in the
maternal serum and amnion.
There's going to be
polyhydramyose, which
is going to be excessive
amniotic fluid.
The reason for that is,
oh, I wrote because,
oh, that's supposed
to be because of.
Because the fetus
doesn't have intact
swallowing centers. They
normally swallow the
amniotic fluid, but
they're unable to do that,
so it becomes excessive.
this condition
and encephaly is
incompatible with life okay
relieving neural tube
defects now we're
talking about disorders
of neuron migration they
can be minor you don't
even notice they're
there or very severe
and the mechanisms
there's going to be loss
of control of neuron
migration along those
glial fibers, and this
is just a repeat of
what you saw before as
a reminder, and so
something has become
disordered there, and
that's just kind of a
repeat of what we said,
but a condition that's
associated with that
is going to be called
the encephaly, and
that is also known as a
gyria which lets you
know what it is but also
it has a name that
goes with it called
smooth brain syndrome so
that kind of tells you
what to expect so a gyria
you're not developing
your gyri and
because that the soul
siren aren't going to
be developing either so
the brain will have a
smooth outer surface
mostly there will be
some grooves and this
MRI showing us that
we have smooth surface
there's some chiroi forming
but otherwise smooth
all the way around
okay so when the baby
is born at nine months
it has the appearance
of a very undeveloped
three four month old
brain and it's associated
with after birth
with a failure to
thrive microencephaly
small brain and CSF
related problems like
hydrocephalus where
excess CSF fluid builds up
and can't get out of
the ventricular system.
There's going
to be marked
developmental delays.
There's going to
be intellectual
disability and often
severe seizures.
Ocular abnormalities
are common
including
microophthalmia.
Okay, skis encephaly,
and skis means split,
as in schizophrenia,
as splitting of the mind.
So there's going to be
clefs, and this is a
pretty dramatic MRI
image that's showing
these clefs. This is a
rendering done by the
computer using data to
make a digital image
of what the data
contains. So you can see
here the outer surface
of the cerebral cortex
like cerebellum now a
large defect here and
they're calling those
clefts within the
hemisphere and this
cleft goes all the way
through to the other
side. So here's where the
CNS is located and
this is a large cleft.
And so this is due
to an abnormality in
morphogenesis once again
we're under the neuron
migration problems
and this is related
the problem with
neurons not migrating
properly so frequently
what you'll see is around
the borders of these
clefts you'll find
microgyria, which will
be tiny convolutions,
not the the ones you
would see normally.
Okay, like what
you do see of the
brain here does
look kind of normal,
but right around
the convolutions,
maybe not so much
on this one, but
you'll see lots of
tiny compilitions.
When it's bilateral,
this would be bilateral,
there's going
to be usually
associated with
severe intellectual
disability,
intractable seizures,
okay, so something
needs to be done,
surgery, medicine,
microcephaly with
******* quadriparesis,
so spasms and
contractions,
things like that,
and hydrocephalus.
If any seizure drugs
don't work, then
sometimes doctors perform
surgeries to remove
parts of the brain
that are causing
that problem, epileptogenic
foci, and those
might have been
surgeries you may have
heard about where
half of the brain was
removed, and the person
went on to live a
long, productive life,
you know, with that
surgery, and their
seizures went away.
all right hydrocephalus
may require surgery
for what's called a
shunt placement and
we'll look at that okay
so we're still talking
about neurons so
heterotopia so neurons
which don't look odd
but they're not in the
right place okay oops
let me go back one
so it can be characterized
as heterotopias
if there's altered
gyral patterns for
what you would think,
what looks normal,
okay, with the
normal gyri and sulci
that are in
humans, or ectopic
neurons in white matter
or periventricular
regions. And I
put a couple of
CTs here to show
you where those are,
okay. so this arrow
here is pointing to this
this line here this
gray line in this dark
field that's going to
be subcortical band
heterotopia it's a thin
layer of gray matter
inside the white matter
they didn't migrate
to the surface they stay
there and they didn't
go all the way to the
surface maybe it's
glial cell or some
other disorder. They're
still working out all
the mechanisms there.
Here we have
periventricular, so see
these are the ventricles,
lateral ventricles,
and you get nodular
heterotopia.
These are just nodules
of gray matter.
They're not supposed
to be here. They
don't look abnormal
under the microscope,
but they're just
there. They're not
performing any useful
function, probably.
So they didn't
migrate superficially
from the edges of
the neural tube.
Okay, so once again, a
neuron migration problem.
So intractable
seizures, once
again, are a
common feature.
There's many genes
that have been
identified that can
cause these conditions.
Okay,
so polymicrogyria.
There was the condition
that we looked
at just a second ago,
that was associated
with these microgyria
regions around
these clasps, and
we'll look at what that
is now. This is
polymicrogyria, which
means multiple regions
with microgyria.
You don't have
the clasps, but
you can have
polymicrogyria in
abnormal areas
of the brain.
Abnormally small
gyri, that's what they
are. And this is a
common location along the
sylvean fissure, and
you can see it here.
This is an area that
looks normal on this
MRI, and these look
like a bunch of small,
many more, but
smaller gyri,
shown in this
diagram too.
They can be from
certain genetic
mutations that have
been discovered,
but also infections
prenatally,
or abnormal twinning,
I can put an
example down,
conjoint twins, okay,
might have this feature.
Most frequent along the
pericillium fissure.
Once again,
drug-resistant
epilepsy could
be a problem.
Paresis and cognitive
impairment are
other problems.
Okay,
so agenesis or
Dysgenesis Disorder.
Okay when we refer to
agenesis, Dysgenesis
Disorder, we're talking
about developmental
disorders and
defective formation of
prosencephalon, which
is D-prosencephalon,
which means there's
inadequate induction of
four brain structures,
and I list them
here, neocortex
hypothalamus hypothalamus
okay so here's one
corpus callosum agenesis
and if you look in
these CT images I mean
MRI I highlight that
this is normal and
MRI you can see the
corpus callosum right
here here is complete
agenesis you see the
cortex, brainstem,
cerebellum, but there's
nothing that looks
like corpus colossum.
So it has, it's a
group of disorders
varying expressions
based on what particular
variety you have,
but when it's an
isolated phenomenon
there's just absence
and there's no other
neurological abnormality
disorders that
can be associated
with it, the patient
may be still normal.
When accompanied
by other problem,
other CNS anomalies,
heterotopias,
polymycogyria,
which is common,
they may have
significant neurological
abnormalities, and I
list a bunch of them And
they include seizure
and vision and hearing
problems, cognitive
difficulties, okay.
Multifactorial causes,
some of the theories
of what's occurring,
direct insult from
a toxin or hypoxia
during the prenatal
period or something
as a direct insult
to developing
structures or destruction
of signaling so
it can be partial
or complete in this
case you don't see
any of the cruxicosm
so that's complete
and moving on to
holoprosencephaly so
I put in there's three
different kinds so I
put this diagram here
so you see that but this
is the kind of effects
that we're talking
about here the midline
forebrain structures
are going to be a
failure of separation
of those and development
of the anterior or
forebrain CNS structures.
And it's not as common,
but cyclopia is one
condition that can occur
with holoprosencephaly
that's associated
with it, and here's
an example of a
newborn demonstrating
cyclopia with the long
eye okay so there's
supposed to be a failure
there's supposed to
be a separation of
the forebrain so this
would be normal okay
here you have low bar
holoprosin simply
here's a semi low bar
all right low bar hello
frozen simply it's
almost divided between
the two lobes of
the cerebral hemispheres
but there's a
little connection right
here in the frontal
lobe semi low bar it's
just a little area
in the back here's
left a lot of it is
unviewed so this is
the least the mildest
form this is mid-range
and this is has the
most severe form the
alovar it's a one big
lobe of cerebral
hemisphere well it's
one cerebrum at that
point so there's some
gene mutations and
sonic hedgehog is one
path something in the
pathway is mutated.
There's a risk
for increased
or pituitary dysfunction.
I list an example.
You can see it in
what's called the
Tau syndrome, which
is trisomy 13.
It can be accompanied
by lots of other
craniofacial avatar
malformations.
I listed one,
the cyclopia,
also cleft palate
is associated.
There could be
a single nostril
for ventilation
that you may see.
This is the semi
-lobar version, so that
would be in the middle,
moderate severity,
and it's going
to reveal a mono
-ventricle, okay, so
just one large ventricle
because there's
incomplete separation
as you can see of
the entire front and
anterior part of the
brain of the cortex.
So microcephaly,
the word micro means
small, so these
are people with
a smaller than
average of brain
material, brain mass.
Because of that,
the head is going
to fall and be
smaller as well.
If the head circumference
is greater than
three standard deviations
below the mean,
then that would be
a definition for
microcephaly for
their age and ***.
There's many
causes, and I list
some of them here,
including genetic,
infectious, list
those there,
teratogenic like
alcohol, hydantoin,
radiation, malnutrition,
hyperthermia,
and it's not
in one in 800 to 5,000.
It's not that common, but
it's not uncommon, okay?
So, you commonly
have developmentally
delayed children, and
as they grow, they
often have intellectual
disability,
or motor
function, speech,
abnormal facial
features, seizures.
In general,
life expectancy is
reduced, and the
prognosis for normal
brain function is poor,
but sometimes,
rarely, occasionally,
one may develop
normal intelligence
and grow normally apart
from having a small
head circumference
so you often see
with other conditions
and if it is
associated with other
conditions they usually
have other comorbid
signs and symptoms
that are occurring in
conjunction with these
various conditions
that are causing
disorder of the CMS.
Megacephaly,
as you can see,
Megala encephaly,
is a large head. So
the average brain
weight is 2.5 standard
deviations above
the mean of the
general population.
Why does this happen?
It's often due to
an number or size
of the brain cells.
It can just be a
familial trait, but there
is a strong link
between genetic pathways
that cause brain
development and
mutations in that
pathway that result in
overgrowth. And here's
an example mutation in
this PI3K pathway
believed to be the
primary cause of this
proliferation and as
far as a condition
that develops the most
common cause is
something called benign
familial megalencephaly
which is what I
was just talking about
some brains are just
large as a normal
family trait inherited
on the dominant
fashion and no other
structural abnormality
or neurologic issues.
Males much more
affected than females,
there's neuropsychiatric
disorders, several
of them associated
with this megalencephaly,
but autism is
most prevalent,
most prevalently
associated.
So the prognosis of
this megalencephaly is
parallels what autism
would be as far as
prognosis okay the
cause is known to be a
part of more than 100
different syndrome for
example hydrocephalus
So, hydrocephalus can
have a part of it,
megalin, macrocephaly.
Oh, there's two
different things here.
Megalincephaly
and macrocephaly.
So, you can have
a large head from
other, for example,
hydrocephaly.
That is an increased
brain mass.
That is fluid,
getting stuck in the
ventricular system.
So, the brain will
increase the size.
So, that would
be called macrocephaly,
a large head.
It's a type,
well, megalencephaly
is a type, it's the
actual brain that's
enlarged in this case.
Okay, so macrocephaly,
megalencephaly are
related but different
in the way I explained.
So posterior
fossa anomalies,
we're going to
talk about Dandy
Walker and Chiari
malformations.
Okay, Dandy Walker,
there's going to
be a large posterior
fossa cyst, okay,
that's going to be
communicating with this
fourth ventricle, and
the fourth ventricle,
remember, it's
going to be just,
there's the fourth
ventricle, it's going to
be just anterior to
the cerebellum, okay,
and here, you see this
large space, fluid
-filled thing, there's
going to be a cyst
back here, it's going
to be in communication
with this fourth
ventricle, and you
see it is right there
and so it's going
to be in communication
with all those
ventricles and that's
due to a parcel or
complete lack of
cerebellar vermis so the
cerebellar lobes
aren't connecting to
each other and there's
going to be a defect
with displacement
of those hemispheres
okay the fourth
ventricle and the
other ventricles can
become enlarged and
dilated with fluid
and And that's
the condition known
as hydrocephalus.
So the posterior
fossa will be
enlarging too,
because of this.
Mortality rate
is 12.5%. Most
commonly is
complications from
this hydrocephalus
that develops.
so this is a clinical
presentation of
Andy Walker usually
presents in the first
year this is just
a little bit of the
explanation of you
know what was happening
okay the first year
with hydrocephalus
and it's often
undiagnosed until oh in
less severe cases so
it's a spectrum are
often undiagnosed
until even adulthood.
So it commonly is
going to present
with, as high
hydrocephalus,
macrocephaly.
Also other
conditions, seizure,
delayed milestones,
so developmental
delays, respiratory
failure,
spina bifida,
and non-communicating
hydrocephalus. So Dandy
Walker, hydrocephalus.
Okay, so this is
part of the development
and there's going to
be some names here
that we didn't go over
for like the pleca
coroidalus which is going
to be this part here
part of the coroid
plexus and that's going
to be interacting with
this AMA anterior
membranous area which is
in the brain stem this
is going to become
the pons area right here
and the lower portion
is going to be known
as the PMA posterior
The PMA, this is just
normal embryogenesis,
is going to interact
with this indentation
that occurs here,
or the tissues
that are, cells
that are around it,
and it's going to
fill with CSF fluid
and make this thing
called Blake's pouch,
okay, so Blake's
pouch is going to
open up and the
cerebellum is and help
form that fourth
ventricle and that
periventricular cistern
or a pericerebellar
cistern in this case
but it's supposed
to regress and also
another thing it's
supposed to do is
supposed to perforate
and then form the
medium form of Magendi.
So a cyst occurs when
the normal outpouncing
of the fourth ventricle
fails to regress
and it persists as
a fourth ventricle
obstructing cyst and
it's going to cause CSF
buildup and hydrocephalus
okay so that's just
an explanation for
how that occurs Chiari
malformations okay
so we talked about
Dandy Walker so this
is another CSF involved
CNS malformation
affecting CSF it's a
collection once again so
there's various degrees
mild to severe forms
and you know different
causes maybe different
genetic disorders
toxin exposures things
like that but there's
it's a collection of
abnormalities from
simple herniation of
the cerebellar tonsils
through the foramen
magnum okay so the
brain stems right
there if you herniate
anything through the
foramen magnum then you're
gonna possibly damage
important respiratory
and cardiac centers
of the brain stem,
possibly, and
complete agenesis
of the cerebellum, okay,
okay,
this says complete
agenesis of the
cerebellum, that
should be cerebellar
vermis, because you
remember it was,
okay, no, that's
Dandy Walker,
cerebellar vermis, yes,
it can go to complete
agenesis of the
cerebellum, it's not
primary agenesis, but
it's, because of these
malformations, the
cerebellum might not
develop properly
multifactorial causes and we're
going to talk about
abnormal CSF dynamics
and probably bring up
hydrocephalus again
that's going to help
guide treatment because
that's going to guide
most of the symptoms
that you see two
different kinds to know
well carry one so
there's It's greater than
5 mm displacement,
and that's shown here.
This is the foramen
magnum. You see part
of the brain stem
and the cerebellar
tonsils, inferior to
the foramen magnum.
Okay, so that's going
to start causing
depression of some
structures here, and probably
part of the ventricular
system, too.
Cary 2 malformation,
the structures
turning through
the foramen magnum
include part of the
cerebellum vermis.
So see,
this is going to
be, because this is
occurring, this could
be occurring during
development, that's
what could be leading to
improper development
of the cerebellum. But
it's also obstructing
structures down here.
So it's going to
be the vermis,
the brain stem,
and the fourth
ventricle that goes
along with them.
So these structures
might be actually
through the
foramen magnum and
kind of squished
at this point. So
that's Chiari 1 and
this is Chiari 2.
So here it's the
tonsils, here
it's all these
other structures.
Chiari 1 is up top
here, Chiari 2 here.
usually asymptomatic
in kids you see it
in adults it varies
from headaches to
myelopathy that's a
spinal cord and brain
stem dysfunction common
symptoms headaches
gets worse with
valsalva maneuvers I
list some of those
here okay 80% have eye,
ear, or cerebellar
dysfunction.
It's associated
with cavities
that form in
the spinal cord.
And these aren't spinal
canal. It's not the
spinal canal we're
talking about. These
are cavities in actual
spinal cord tissue.
And that's called
syringomyelia,
that disorder.
and it's going to be
within a structure
called a syrinx, which
is the fluid-filled cyst
that develops within
the spinal cord. And
that's because CSF
can't go through these
other structures, so
it's forced to go in
around the spinal canal
of the spinal cord.
There will be
commonly C7 through
12 cranial nerve
dysfunction,
but usually managed
conservatively,
you know, follow
-up imaging,
make sure nothing
is getting worse,
you know, treat them
symptomatically.
Here,
herniation causes non
-communicating hydrocephalus
due to obstruction
of this aqueduct.
Okay.
And they may develop
a lumbosacral
myelomeningocele as well.
Okay, so differences in
Chiari-2 from Chiari-1,
greater than 95% have
this myelomeningocele.
With myelomeningocele,
we'll have this
Chiari-2, so there's
a strong association.
So the leading cause
of death with these
people who have these
myelomeningocele,
since they are
associated with Chiari
-2, is going to be
this hydrocephalus,
since that's going
to be a problem that
develops with this
Chiari-2 alteration.
So about a third develop
brainstem symptoms by H5,
a third of those
will unfortunately
die usually
of respiratory
failure, remember
brainstem, right?
Usually presents as a
neurosurgical emergency
and the goal is to
relieve pressure
from the brain stem
and allow CSF to flow
okay so if they need
help it's going to
present this emergency
and surgery to do
those things that's
Chiari 2 other Chiari
malformations you
have to know about the
other two these
ones are just more
completeness three is
rare it's most severe and
seldom compatible
with life There's
profound herniation and
dysfunction of brain
tissue. It even
protrudes through the
skull through a defect
there, brain tissue.
Chiari 4 includes
cerebellar
hypoplasia and
herniation.
There's also a Chiari
0, syringomyelia,
no herniation. There's
a Chiari 1.5, which
has severity in between,
so it's moderate
severity, in between
carry one and two
other conditions syrinx
and uh syringomyelia
okay and i told
you the relations
between those and
hydrocephalus okay uh
syringomyelia uh csf
well kind of went over
this already but
here's a picture that
shows you what that
looks like okay so you
get this fluid-filled
cavity that develops
in the spinal cord,
okay, there's a T1
MRI, 70% of cases of
congenital Chiari 1,
okay,
so here's a
theory, I already
told you that
theory, okay,
you can see with
posterior fossa tumors,
you can see this
kind of obstruction
of flow around
the foramen magnum
okay but also you
know also obviously
with these carrying
alformations so
other conditions like
trauma infections
sorry trauma infections
so it's not just
this that can can
box in as well you
know trauma infectious
processes subarachnoid
hemorrhage can
cause inflammation
and scarring and that
can block CSF flow
okay so if it's blocked
you could end up
If it blocks somewhere
down here, you
could end up with the
syringomyelia developing
in these other
conditions as well.
So just remember syrinx
is a tube like a syringe.
Clinic presentation
of syrinx
and this is from
Nader, he puts
a nice diagram
together here.
And this will be
important to know, it
might even be on the
board, is usually
the common physical
manifestation of a
cervical thoracic
syrinx is a cape-like
pain temperature
distribution disruption
okay so loss and
pain and temperature
sensation paresthesia
in the cape-like
pattern in the upper
extremities okay
why is that there's
an explanation given
here and that's because
it crosses from from
one side to the other
very close to the spinal
canal where these
syringomyelia tend to
be developing near or
in and that could cause
injury cause compression
injuries and you
know, block off blood
flow, block off axonal
transport, so, so,
and that's why you get
that pain temperature
disruption, but it's
in that pattern, because
you're disrupting
the spinothalamic tract
that crosses over.
hydrocephalus the
most common condition
treated by pediatric
neurosurgeons
so
megalencephaly
oh macrocephaly
macroencephaly is
going to be the
condition that
is commonly going
to be you know
parents are going to
start seeing the head
get a little bit bigger
and get concerned
bring the patient
to the pediatrician
It's not a specific
disease, many
different things
cause hydrocephalus,
it's the result
of impaired
circulation of
CSF or absorption.
So there's lots of
congenital conditions,
we went over quite
a few of them,
but there's tumors, we
went over hemorrhages,
post-surgical,
there will be
scarring, post-traumatic,
we went over that
one. So there's
congenital and acquired,
okay.
here we are with
macrocephaly and
babies and young kids
have open sutures
called fontanelles
and that helps
when their brain is
growing their CNS
is growing and as the
head size increases
and here's a chart from
CDC that shows normal
demographics for how
brain should be growing
at certain times during
a child's development
and what this does
is measure head
circumference over here
and this top looks like
it would be two so it
goes by months up top
so this chart goes up
to three years so most
important early finding
is head circumference
changing percentiles
so with a short
period of time it goes
from 50th percentile
up to the 90th, so in
the middle up to here,
then maybe
that's something
to be concerned about.
The typical signs and
symptoms are going
to be increased
intracranial pressure
because of possible
hydrocephalus.
It's going to
be vomiting,
ataxia, papilledema.
In severe cases you get
profound macrocephaly
okay so this is three
months old right
here with looks like a
pretty severe case of
hypercephalus and
would need treatment
here's how management
of hypercephalus may
occur it's usually
surgical you can put a vp
shunt in and that's with
a catheter and that's
going to and that's
short for ventricular
peritoneal because
you have a catheter
that That extends from
a ventricle, usually,
passes through a
valve, and then
under the skin
into the perineal
cavity where excess
of CSF drains.
Yeah,
and that's just
one way. I mean,
there's probably
other ways,
but this is one
that I've seen.
Cerebral palsy disorder
of movement, and
development of that
movement, and posture.
here. And it's
due to something
that's not
progressing, it's
a disturbance
that occurred
while they were
prenatal, while they
were developing.
They got it and that
developed their
cerebral palsy and it's
kind of set at that
stage right now.
Of course the patient
can deteriorate
because of these
disabilities, but the
disabilities themselves
aren't set to get worse.
They've already had
the insult occur.
So it's not
progressive and it
occurred in
developing, if it were
acquired cerebral
palsy can happen in
the first month,
postnatally even.
So, that's because
these insults to
the CNS can occur
prenatal, during birth,
or the first couple
of years, okay,
while the CNS is
developing rapidly,
but 90% are injured
before or during birth.
The most common cause
of the CNS injury
is going to be a
perinatal ******. It can
be hemorrhagic,
ischemic, thromboembolic.
The second cause
is infantile
meningitis or
encephalitis.
Also could be *****,
some kind of trauma, for
example motor
vehicle accident.
********* birth is a
leading risk factor
for cerebral palsy
because you need to
undergo a lot of
development before
those nine months get
there for your CNS.
okay so i put uh this
in here because with
cerebral palsy there
are uh different it's a
movement disorder
right so you can have
different kinds of patterns
you have ******* uh
where you're stiff
and you might have uh
you know uh sudden you
know um brisk movements
of certain muscles
that just almost twitch
and it seems like it's
under-controllable.
Athetoid, that's
like a writhing
moment. Atax, it
has to do with
posture, and it
can be mixed, okay?
So if it's an
infant and they're
supposed to have these
primitive reflexes
and they're not
yet having those
when they should,
then that might be a
clue that there
might have been some
insult in the
prenatal period, okay?
So, it's a movement
disorder, so
intellect and
cognition are intact,
this is a motor
system problem.
They may adopt
certain postures
and common ones
are arms and legs,
flexion, arms are pulled
in and hands are flexed,
flexion of the
hips, knees,
toes, abduction
of the hips,
there's spasticity, we
already talked
about that,
various movement
disorders,
dystonia, ataxia
or chorioathetosis
imaging usually
normal and
thank you i really
appreciate your time
and um if you have
any questions please
feel free to send
me an email give
me a call or if you're
here in jonesboro
uh room is 424f and
i'm here a lot if
not send me an email
or call thank you